einen schönen guten morgen aus berlin
vierter tag der haushaltsberatung im
bundestag letzter tag der
haushaltsberatungen damit und dieser tag
der hat es noch mal wirklich in sich
denn der bundestag der wird heute
zahlreiche weitreichende beschlüsse
fassen und das ist ein besonderer tag
weil zum einen der bundeshaushalt 2022
verabschiedet werden soll der erste
haushalt der ampel koalition und ein
zusätzlich einen 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr dafür
wird extra das grundgesetz heute
geändert zudem will heute die
ampelkoalition den gesetzlichen
mindestlohn auf 12 eur anheben ab
oktober wird das dann der fall sein und
eine rekordverdächtige
rentenanpassung die soll heute auch noch
auf den weg gebracht werden also sie
hören dass das ist wirklich ein
besonderer tag auch hier für die
parlamentarier und natürlich gibt es da
auch zahlreiche abstimmung um einen
überblick über diesen tag zu bekommen
habe ich mit zwei gäste eingeladen und
ich freue mich dass wir heute morgen zu
mir gekommen sind es sind zwei
parlamentarische geschäftsführer der
fraktion katja mast spd fraktion die
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
und thorsten frei für die
cdu/csu-fraktion der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
gerade die parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer sind ja die manager hier
im parlament der fraktion müssen
natürlich an diesem tag einen guten
überblick haben über die abstimmung aber
auch über die themen deswegen wollen wir
diesen tag ein bisschen sortieren diese
woche diese haushaltswoche stand unter
dem eindruck die debatten waren
dominiert thema angriffskrieg russland
auf die ukraine ganz eindeutig das hat
hier die auch die einzelplan beratung
tatsächlich sehr dominiert nun ist es
aber so dass
[Musik]
heute
zusätzlich das ist eine folge des
angriffskrieges 1 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr auf
den weg gebracht werden soll damit wird
die zeitenwende politik von olaf scholz
konkret frau mast es wird mutmaßlich
nein stimmen und enthaltungen aus spd
und grüne fraktion geben inwiefern ist
es denn heute auch ein gradmesser für
den rückhalt aus der koalition für den
bundeskanzler mir zuerst einmal bin ich
froh dass wir dieses sondervermögen
heute verabschieden können hat der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz drei tage nach
dem angriff krieg putins in der ukraine
angekündigt und es kommt das ist nicht
der einzige bestandteil der zeitenwende
wir liefern zum beispiel waffen in die
ukraine das haben wir vorher auch nicht
getan wir müssen uns aber auch mit
themen wie inflation sozialen
zusammenhalt usw beschäftigen ganz
wichtig und ich gehe von der breiten
unterstützung in der spd
bundestagsfraktion für dieses
sondervermögen aus weil es geht ja darum
im kern dass wir die bundeswehr nach den
letzten 16 jahren auf die höhe der zeit
holen die soldatinnen und soldaten gut
ausstatten die verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit herstellen und
gleichzeitig dass diese wichtigen und
großen investitionen nicht in konkurrenz
zu unseren ganzen sozial und
klimapolitischen vorhaben stehen wie
viele fehlende stimmen darf sich die
ampel der erlauben dass zellen war am
schluss wenn die abstimmung da ist aber
ich gehe von der sehr breiten
unterstützung die cdu csu fraktion hat
im februar dem kanzler durchaus beifall
gespendet als er seine zeitenwende rede
gehalten hat vor allem als es um die
bundeswehr ausstattung ging es wurde
wochenlang verhandelt über dieses 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen dann gab
es die woche noch mal ein bisschen
zeitliche verzögerung wie viel
unterstützung wird es denn heute von
seiten der union für diesen plan des
kanzlers geben denn ihr fraktionschef
friedrich merz hatte zwischendurch mal
gesagt man würde rechnerisch nur die
nötigen stimmen liefern für die
zweidrittelmehrheit um die zu erreichen
also wir werden sowohl des bundeswehr
finanzierungsgesetz als auch die
zugrunde liegende grundgesetzänderung
aus voller überzeugung und mit voller
kraft unterstützen also als fraktion
geschlossen dieses paket unterstützen
weil wir es für richtig halten wir haben
am 27 februar hatte im bundeskanzler
nicht nur applaudiert sondern viele
meiner kollegen waren begeistert ob
dieser sicherheitspolitischen
zeitenwende die in der tat notwendig ist
sie haben die wochenlangen verhandlungen
angesprochen die wehren aus unserer
sicht nicht nötig gewesen auf das was
wir am sonntag vereinbart haben hätten
wir uns schon vor vielen wochen
verständigen können es ist ja im grunde
nicht nur so dass wir uns als union
durchgesetzt haben wir haben uns mit dem
durchgesetzt was der bundeskanzler für
richtig gehalt hat nun angekündigt hat
es war der zerstrittenheit der ampel und
der drei koalitionspartner geschuldet
dass es so lange gedauert hat jetzt gibt
der einigung also ihre beiden fraktionen
werden mutmaßlich heute mehrheitlich für
dieses 100 milliarden sondervermögen
stimmen sondervermögen zusätzlich zum
haushalt es sind auch sonder schulden
vom ast jessica rosenthal
juso-vorsitzende mitglied ihrer fraktion
hat im spiegel ein namens artikel
geschrieben und hat gefragt was sollen
wir den eltern sagen die fragen warum
die schultoiletten nicht saniert werden
was sollen wir den pflegekräften sagen
die fragen warum kein geld für eine
bessere bezahlung da ist aber 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr was
antworten sie denen also zuerst mal ist
ja durch diesen angriffskrieg der in der
ukraine
stattfindet heute ist der hundertste tag
hat sich ja die internationale
sicherheitslage die internationalen
abkommen fundamental verändert die
größte atommacht der welt und
militärmacht der welt annektiert greift
ein anderes land völkerrechtswidrig an
das habe ich mir in meiner generation
auf jeden fall nicht vorstellen können
alle die heute sagen sie wussten das
frage ich mich was haben sie denn vorher
dagegen getan und wir merken dass die
frage der äußeren sicherheit eine neue
dimension hat deshalb müssen wir die
bundeswehr ausstatten nach 16 jahren cdu
minister im verteidigungsministerium 16
jahre kanzlerin der cdu sage ich die
bundeswehr ist nicht bei den soldatinnen
soldaten auf der höhe der zeit und wir
müssen sie ausstatten dann ist nur noch
die frage machen wir das aus dem ganz
normalen haushalt und damit in
konkurrenz zu unseren ganzen
sozialpolitischen form sie haben ja auch
schon gesagt wir machen heute das renten
paket 1 wir haben hier aber noch mit der
kindergrundsicherung in denen wir kinder
aus armut rausholen dem ganzen
transformationsprozess wo wir
beschäftigung zukunftsfähig machen
möchten in deutschland viele viele große
aufgaben die angegangen werden müssen
und deshalb und des und genau deshalb
machen wir das sondervermögen damit
diese ausstattung die notwendig ist
absolut nicht in konkurrenz zu allem ja
wir müssen ja gleich ob dafür noch geld
als er frei wenn ich aber tatsächlich
dazu fragen darf die 100 milliarden sind
riesen schulden nicht nur für die
nächsten jahre sondern auch für die
nächste legislaturperiode ganz egal wer
regieren würde
begrenzt diese diese äußeren zwänge die
es gibt sie haben es gesagt die
außenpolitische lage natürlich hat sich
verändert begrenzt dass die spielräume
für zukünftige generationen für
politische entscheidung ja das ist ganz
eindeutig so und man muss es wirklich
sagen dass es das problem am ende dieser
haushaltswoche politik ist das setzen
von schwerpunkten und zu glauben dass
man sich um einen bereich stärker
engagieren kann ohne dass das
auswirkungen auf andere bereiche hat ist
natürlich eine milchmädchenrechnung
deswegen muss man wirklich sagen wir
haben es hier mit einer
sicherheitspolitischen zeitenwende zu
tun das findet aber im haushalt keine
entsprechen wir haben keine
haushaltspolitische zeitenwende es
werden die schwerpunkte nicht richtig
gesetzt und es ist natürlich eine
belastung für zukünftige generationen
deswegen haben wir hier auch anträge
dazu gestellt wie man die
neuverschuldung geringer erhöhen kann
aber es sonder schulden werden sie ja
jetzt erst mal mittragen das ist eine
richtige schwerpunkt das ist jetzt
notwendig deswegen machen
ja es war die spd dies verhindert hat
liebe katja mast da gibt es viele
beispiele die fresken hat noch vor
wenigen wochen gespräche liege unschuld
als als als für die bundeswehr geld
ausgeben das ist die wahrheit und
deswegen müssen wir das jetzt auch
gemeinsam bereinigen 100 milliarden für
die bundeswehr milliarden für corona
hilfen nach wie vor milliarden für die
folgen des krieges all das bildet sich
im haushalt ab also ein wesentlicher
teil auch des bundeshaushaltes fließt in
die krisenbewältigung
jetzt kommen wir noch mal zu dem was sie
angesprochen haben wie viel geld wird
überhaupt noch da sein gerade für die
sozial politischen projekte die sich die
spd vorgenommen hat kindergrundsicherung
und bürger geld dafür steht davon steht
ja nicht zum haushalt ja wir haben sie
ja noch mehr sozialpolitische themen
vorgenommen zb langfristige
stabilisierung des rentenniveaus halte
ich auch für sehr wichtig und natürlich
werden wir uns in dieser koalition auch
im zuge der künftigen
haushaltsberatungen austauschen müssen
wie wir mit unseren vorhaben umgehen
aber ich gehe davon aus dass wir nicht
nur die ausgabenseite anschauen und dann
auch die einnahmeseite weil wir darüber
diskutieren müssen und wir haben ja
nicht nur die sozialpolitischen themen
die müssen wir machen damit wir den
zusammenhalt im land stärken nur dann
bekommen wir akzeptanz für die enormen
transformationsprozesse vor denen wir
stehen die ganzen klimaprojekte den
umbau der industriegesellschaft und das
sind ja alles punkte wofür auch dieser
zusammenhalt notwendig ist und deshalb
bin ich sehr zuversichtlich uns sehr
sicher dass wir in dieser koalition in
dieser fortschritts koalition gemeinsame
lösungen für aber die
kindergrundsicherung nur um ein beispiel
zu nehmen der zeitplan den lisa paus die
bundesfamilienministerin vorgelegt hat
der sieht vor dass die
kindergrundsicherung wahrscheinlich erst
zum ende der legislatur kommen wird das
ist ein zentrales vorhaben der koalition
ja aber die kindergrundsicherung ist ja
ein komplexität auch nicht zu
unterbieten weil sie nämlich in
verschiedene sozialgesetzbücher hinein
weg und ich bin ja viele jahre
sozialpolitikerin gewesen bevor ich
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
geworden bin und glaube dass es da
wirklich sinnvoll ist alle aspekte gut
abzuwägen und es gut auf den weg zu
bringen wir werden uns da auch eng mit
den bundesländern abstimmen müssen und
deshalb glaube ich hat frau aus sicher
ein sehr vernünftigen zeitpunkt vor
gericht wir wollen noch ganz kurz einen
blick auf den mindestlohn werfen weil
das heute auch ein großes thema ist
erhöhung des ministers 12 euro
frau mast der sprung auf 12 euro die
politik greift eines ist eigentlich
sache der mindestlohn kommission aus
gewerkschaften und arbeitnehmern hat die
mindestlohn-kommission keinen guten job
gemacht das geht gar nicht darum ob die
mindestlohn-kommission einen guten job
macht oder nicht sondern ob die
entwicklung des mindestlohns insgesamt
den mindestlohn an die einkommens mitte
herangeführt hat in den letzten jahren
es geht darum dass sechs millionen
menschen heute von den zwölf euro
mindestlohn erhöhungen profitieren und
meinen kollegen frei kann ich nur sagen
nachdem im landtagswahlkampf in
nordrhein-westfalen der anschein erweckt
worden ist dass die cdu jetzt endlich
nicht mehr von uns gezwungen werden muss
beim mindestlohn mitzumachen sondern
auch zwölf euro will ist also eine
enthaltung wie heute ist keine haltung
zur frage der würde der arbeit für die
unteren lohngruppen in unserem land und
ich bin wirklich stolz dass wir das
heute verabschieden können im deutschen
presse-agentur sandte wollte der union
die sie noch mal vielleicht erklären
müssen herr frey die union eigentlich
erst gegen den gesetzlichen mindestlohn
in den vergangenen jahren es gab
tatsächlich eine kölner erklärung der
cdu und csu in diesem frühjahr das man
wegen der inflation an der erhöhung des
mindestlohns durchaus positiv gegenüber
steht heute enthält sich die union sind
sie für oder gegen den gesetzlichen
mindestlohn auf 12 euro zu erhöhen wir
erhalten einen mindestlohn von zwölf
euro pro stunde für angemessen und
richtig dass es überhaupt keine frage
denn sie haben zu recht darauf wie sie
lesen in den letzten zwei jahren haben
wir zehn prozent inflation in
deutschland gehabt deswegen ist es
durchaus angemessen und richtig wir
halten den weg dahin für falsch weil die
lohnfindung ist aufgabe der tarif der
sozialpartner und nicht des parlaments
und es gibt natürlich schon die
befürchtung dass dann in jedem wahlkampf
darum gestritten wird wie der richtige
mindestlohn aussieht dass es in der
sozialen marktwirtschaft nicht der
richtige weg deswegen haben wir unsere
abstimmung auch mit einem
entschließungsantrag verbunden wo wir
genau darauf hinweisen dass das ziel in
ordnung ist der weg dahin aber falsch
man könnte den weg dahin auch anders
finden indem man die rahmenbedingungen
und kehlen für die
mindestlohn-kommission verändern würde
das würden wir für den richtigen des
falles nebelkerzen
einkommenssicherheit und einkommens
stärkung über tarif und mindestlohn
jetzt nur mit der spd geben nein es ist
sicherlich falsch es geht darum wie wir
den richtigen weg finden und das ist bei
uns der weg der sozialen marktwirtschaft
das macht den erfolg der bundesrepublik
deutschland und auch den erfolg der
menschen hier aus wir könnten darüber
noch sehr viel länger sprechen sie beide
müssen aber dringend rein katja mast
thorsten frei beide erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer denn es
gibt gleich eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte deswegen vielen
dank dass ihr heute morgen noch bei uns
waren und wir werden den tag natürlich
mit spannung verfolgen vielen dank danke